[Music]
thank you
hello good morning good afternoon
good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world welcome I forgot about night time
then for a second my brain literally
forgot like Darkness I could only
remember good morning and good afternoon
I'm sure that you're the one closest to
Darkness right now too
it's getting you know Autumn's coming
it's getting dark here like five o'clock
it's like I've had such a long warm hot
summer here it's like mental that there
it's like cold and wet it's like it's
raining so strange I'm British
anyway anywho hey guys and as always
welcome stormy bear how are you doing
sir doing well today how are you hey
guys
what the [ __ ] was that
Paris
we're good I think we're good over here
okay I did some noise come out of your
butt anyway Harris how you doing
pretty good tired but pretty good just
been seeing way too many movies this
past weekend no oh you look at you
having to like Halloween party started
so
oh yeah there is that there was that
yeah we're getting um Christmas has
started here too much so I'm like it's
not Halloween yet stop putting Christmas
trees up oh my God
do you know for everybody that puts a
Christmas tree up in November a baby elf
dies
oh you've really gotta stop doing it you
know Iceland doesn't have that many
inhabitants anymore all the elves are
going out
[Music]
they can all grow up to be legless you
know maybe
maybe I'll clean right so
we're here today we're going to talk
about the DC but before that we'll do it
we always do and we'll have a little bit
of a chat about what we've seen this
week so stormy back why don't you kick
us off sir what sort of thing you've
been watching okay so I've watched this
one thing is on uh Disney plus it was a
werewolf by night it was like a one hour
show it started off as real uh Art Deco
real Gothic looking black and white I
really can't try to mimic a old monster
movie from the 50s it actually had in
the corner of the frame every once in a
while it have like a little cigarette
burn to change the Reel and it was
really well done it was just it wasn't
serious it was huh I didn't notice that
that's genius
yeah yeah it was just uh
but it was just a one-off I think Marvel
uh Disney called the special
presentation is one hour but it was
really good you notice I guess you could
say it's a monster buddy movie once
you've seen it it was just
it I I it deserved to be a series I
thought or at least a two-hour movie but
it was just really good and sometimes
now going back into
marvel-ish I was wondering and Harris
did you see this
um
Bloodstone was an infinity stone was it
the ether
again that never occurred to me either I
just sat and enjoyed it I didn't I
didn't think about it as much as you saw
me it would make sense wouldn't actually
it behaved in a similar way
right right longevity longevity in life
power all this other stuff I thought it
was very well done
the Bloodstone family and the actual
character the character the the stone
itself are very important for the
monsters for the MCU which hopefully we
get because that will feel fresh and
good with it
sorry go on oh and the another thought I
had to
um get around any kind of uh timeline
discrepancies I was wondering it since
it's the the
um
uh The Ether infinity stone is really
kind of a gas I was wondering if it
could ever be split up
okay Bloodstone
dark out
you know
it would make sense so you could bottle
it and and sell it yeah yeah I think I
wonder if we could burn it
the snake World salesman but ether
instead
well yeah exactly but I say I actually
like that
um and I I I I I know they're trying to
expand their
I sounded rude for some reason I don't
know why um but they're going to do
different things I hope though they'll
stop trying to do different things with
the actual like superhero characters
like She-Hulk and do things like this
instead if they want to be creative and
they want to expand their brand do stuff
like that it was great
um if you haven't done it yet definitely
go watch it
um but yeah stop messing around with the
superhero stuff though that stuff we
just want them to be We Want superhero
get angry punch somebody in the face we
don't want that to be too clever we'll
talk about that that's gravity but don't
don't dangle any fish in front of my
face you know so here's the Marvel
Encyclopedia right another bloody book
it's a little bit thick
and most of the things in here
there's Swordsmen they're surge they're
swarm there's Humanity guy there's a I
mean there's all of these Mr Fantastic
we've heard of him but there's so many
characters in here that's just never
been touched
you know certainly we don't have to
regurgitate the same
dozen or so characters
over and over and over there's more to
the Marvel Universe than
don't get touched at some point
um
other things I watched this weekend
um the peripheral
very good on Amazon
uh
it was written by William Gibson who's I
don't know if you're familiar with his
work but he's also the author of a
Neuromancer and some other
um
cybernetic cyberpunk novels very good
some are also very violent
they're very good
this star is Chloe Moretz I forget her
middle name Chloe Grace
oh my God kick ass
I would I would say a quote but I don't
want to demonetize your channel it's
um
it's kind of you know uh Oculus gone bad
kind of thing you know those Oculus
goggles really gone bad and uh
and and she her and her family live in
the Appalachian Mountains I used to live
very it was very well done
and of course
got caught up on House of the dragon and
indoor polished off The Walking Dead as
much has been released uh start I'm on
season three now I think of Fear The
Walking Dead
um so I'm up to where
um the Abomination is She-Hulk gets
released from prison and of course so
the fine Leaf saw the first episode of
the last season of lower decks oh my God
the Easter eggs keep coming very very
um
and something that's that's really not
it's kind of sci-fi but not really it's
a documentary on math called a trip to
infinity and it touches a lot of issues
concerning science fiction space travel
and speed of light and what Infinity is
and it really puts into context the
stories that we Yammer on about every
weekend and it's on Netflix
it's very well done it's very well done
it's our fans and nids let's be honest
yeah that's true you'll enjoy that I I
do want to talk about the peripheral a
bit more but we'll
um how about you Harris why are you even
watching this week sir
well you know me I've been in theater a
little too much as usual but I I am
excited to check out the peripheral I'm
going to use y'all too as my my gauging
meter to actually press play or not but
I'm gonna end up probably pressing play
but I had watched Andor and House of the
Dragon I'm excited for the season finale
or it's not series but season finale of
house the dragon tonight
um I've like I said I've been in the
movie theater a little too much I saw a
ticket to Paradise
tar
and banshees in a Sharon within the last
two days what did you think of the
Banshees again not sci-fi but
a lot of critical Acclaim but it looks
boring as crap oh have you seen any
Martin mcdonic films
I probably
did you see in Bruges
the same actors
it's
it's presented as a straight comedy and
it's funny it's really funny the entire
time is funny but it's very serious in
its own way as well so I I wouldn't
necessarily say it's a comedy it's like
a drama satire or just a satirical drama
I thoroughly thoroughly enjoyed it it's
a little more serious than I expected it
to be but that I think it plays into the
film and it's good because of it but
then I saw tar right after Kate
blanchett's new film about her being a
composer and she's going to give
Michelle yo a little bit of at least of
a run of her money for the best actress
nomination because damn that was good
that was good intense
but good
okay
um I know you've seen something else at
the cinema but we're going to hold off
on that because it'll lead really nicely
into what we're going to talk about
today so uh I watched the uh newest
episode of lower decks uh trusted
sources and Harris you do have to watch
this episode because at the very end of
the episode spoilers the
um
the the oh God I forgot the [ __ ] name
of the ship serious ceresis that's not
right
burritos thank you God know where did
that go in my head
um but the Cerritos is saved by a new
class of um Federation Starship the
Texas class
a little bit of a spoiler it's actually
like a it's a drone Starship basically
it's an unmanned automated Starship and
it kicks ass there's three bring
Cruisers
um and they're attacking the Cerritos
and they're wiped out and then this
thing turns up and just the spank some
um I mean like immediately
um so it actually makes sense I don't
really anyone's ever thought of actually
having an automated Starship before
particularly you know when we're
anti-borg but yeah I thought the Texas
class because because is that a metaphor
they're taking the piss out of Texans
like all guns no brains I'm not quite
sure but um
someone smart how to program it we got
brains we're the number one place in the
world for medicine and Aeronautics or
typically with NASA yeah
an episode in Voyager where there was a
Starship that was uh supposed to be
automated uh yeah
fully automated was it it was the one
that split into three the um I mean the
three uh the doctor was on there with
also another oh God another
um
it was the it was the emo program
um it was the medical program but it was
the next it was the newest version it
was played by
a little Weasley far
I'm gonna have to look at the name of
that Starship now you've all bloody
um but but yeah it was supposed to be
that was supposed to be one of those
anti-borg
um starships that they built but I never
made a little sense to mix it split into
three how is that going to surround a
cube it would have just got blasted but
okay I'm not gonna look it up but yeah
that could operate with a minimal crew
it's not supposed to operate completely
autonomously
um so this could be the first ship
that's like completely autonomous
so trekkies are going crazy
so that's cool though that's an
interesting just concept because all the
time and we have drones in real life I
mean all the time but within sci-fi you
can see autopiloted ships all the time
or people with skeleton Crews A robot's
driving for them and they don't really
have to pay attention because they don't
really want to be a drone ship the
Prometheus clouds
thank you yes it was the Prometheus and
the episode is called Prometheus I think
it wasn't
um we saw the Prometheus a few more
times and I say it made sense against
multi-vector Attack Mode that was what
it's called and it's just yeah and
swarmed them makes sense against smaller
vessels it just never makes sense
against a borg for me but um but but
yeah so the other thing I watched the
same as you still me I watched
peripheral last night
um I've just done a video released it
about an hour ago and basically saying
because I get loads of comments about
people saying about the new Stargate and
goes ah they'll ruin it they'll just
make it woke and I'm like does Amazon
really make a lot of like woke TV shows
and I really hate that word I'm sorry I
hate it so much but
um it's you know what I mean when I used
it so
um I was thinking okay I'm a decently
get accused of it a lot but Amazon make
the boys
Clarkston farm and Jeremy Camp at least
woke person has ever lived
um man in the High Castle you know I
listed five or six shows a very
different sorts of shows but you cannot
accuse him of being like that particular
work I know people got annoyed about
rings of power I disagree with them but
they did and Wheel of Time but again
it doesn't it's it's not a trend or is
it but also they make this peripheral
I'm not saying peripheral is even
remotely woke it's it's a fantastic TV
show it's got lots of layers to it
um do I want a spoiler
we'll put a spoiler alert on the The
Twist at the end I did see coming but
it's clever as hell
I'm not going to ruin it for anyone
actually we won't but um it's really
really clever like I saw it coming about
four minutes before and I went to the
wife I'm like
I don't think it's that I think it's
this and she was like what that doesn't
make sense in a five minutes later it
was like ah
um but it's a really clever twist
um I've never read the book but I have I
did read Necromancer so I knew I had an
idea what this guy was like
um yeah
exactly well the room is as well that um
the next big thing they Amazon wants to
make Necromancer as well they've
actually got a deal for a few of his
books
yeah so they're going to make
Necromancer as well
um
that will be a very violent absolutely
um but that that's going to be a movie
apparently not a series
but um that'll be different make a make
a series and make a movie instead of a
series
but um
but but yeah I I can't I can't say
enough good things about this show I
thought it was actually even my wife
liked it I thought it was really clever
I thought it was a bit of sass to it it
had a bit
um uh you know it was really intelligent
something it's just it was action
there's you know there's fighting
there's guns there's you know um there's
loads of things going on you don't quite
know what it is yet legal drug
distribution yeah check legal drug
distribution which is always fun West
Virginia being in the Appalachian
Mountains and the worst state in the
nation for the fentanyl abuse
no it wasn't no it wasn't it was
somewhere like Louisiana or something
that was so but that was the map that
was a thing uh I'm not what's it called
noxy that's not right oxy
okay
Oxycontin yeah there you go that was a
big one dope sick if you haven't seen
that it's not sci-fi
I've not seen it
kind of Michael Keaton did an excellent
job in it
now Michael King does a great job of
everything he's such a great actor
um but yeah I mean I can't I can't say
enough nice things about enough good
things about performance I'm generally
looking forward to the next episode to
the second episode is already out I'm
checking that out tonight
um you have to concentrate yes you can't
just sort of um
wander off and make a difficulty because
you will now have no clue what's going
on when you come back and it's
beautifully made as well absolutely
beautiful
so so anyway
the other thing I watched and I know
Harris has watched as well was Black
Adam
and that sort of inspired our
conversation
um topic today
because I actually
um
liked Black Adam but I'm not gonna go as
far as saying I loved it it's not even
my favorite DC movie
Harris what's your what was your initial
feelings about it
obviously I mean I I went in wanting it
to be good I really wanted it to be good
but I didn't expect it to be good at all
whatsoever hmm so when I walked out I
was a lot happier than I expected to be
and my once were satiated uh in a in a
way I kind of the first thing that I
thought when I left it was
this could have been phenomenal I feel
like all the bullet points and all the
story points even with kind because I
thought the film was almost going to end
when he was should we give spoilers or
no
uh as I'm just gonna give a spoiler a
look as long as I'm stormy you haven't
seen it so do you mind
it's not going to ruin the whole film
for you about no this there's just a
certain part of the film where it
legitimately seems like it's about to
end and then of course the whole third
act happens but it does feel like it's
going to end at that point and I was
like okay maybe this is why the critics
aren't very fond of it because it's it's
a very self-contained and shorter film
than I expected it to be then you get
the third act that you expect but it's
it's a decent third act it's nothing out
of
the norm per se but I I also feel like
it was well done and I don't I don't
even like saying it because I don't want
to poo poo on a director at all and the
director that directed this did really
well with the orphan I haven't seen the
jungle cruise but jungle cruise is
supposed to be decent for a Disney film
and I just feel like if they would have
gotten a director with more experience
for something this scale of a film
it could have been not Sam Remy's
Spider-Man 2 but it could have been
Spider-Man 3 or above you know but then
you think that the third Act was a
little bit rushed I don't know
I mean for me it's like you know it's
like 90 there and then it still had 90
to go I didn't think you'd seen it
stormy so you have seen it then oh I
haven't seen it
stop talking about things you haven't
seen like you have like God said I mean
you know I thought the Betrayal of Dr
Fate you know uh by Pierce Brosnan was
really getting was it 007 but we're
usually seeing him in but um go ahead
shut me up he's frosting it is actually
his brother was the singular best part
the only thing I have to really correct
you on is it that Spider-Man 3 is
terrible
I just said
Spider-Man 2 is amazing and I don't know
if Spider-Man's I I would kind of put
Black Adam right I don't know if I'd put
it behind Spider-Man 3 I'd have to I'd
have to
justify three is good it's the second
half that's terrible
and that's a film that should have been
loads better than it was
just Sandman it would be great yeah they
over did they threw too much crap at it
I think parts of Black Adam though it's
a similar problem is it was it was just
too much they they it was the story went
over the top and I know they've got to
make black Black Adam
able to stand up against Superman
because that's going to be the point of
the movie uh the the the series of where
they're going now and they're promising
a slow burn so they won't do another DC
but we'll talk about that in a minute as
well
um
but anyway without going on too much
about Black Adam but like I said we've
enjoyed I thought some of the effects
are a bit dodgy in places but on the
whole I enjoyed it
um I don't know how they made some of
those effects that dodgy but I've
written out a list of all the DC EU
movies up till now if I quickly run
through them and you just give like a
thumbs up or a thumbs down overall for
each movie so I don't know thumbs up I'd
quite happily watch it again it's great
thumbs down I never ever want to watch
that movie again I don't like it fair
enough
so Man of Steel
okay we'll go with that as a I'll allow
that I will allow really I I love Henry
Cavill I just that movie is just it's
not Superman
don't even get me started
what's the next on your list I'm so
angry I mean no we're coming back to it
I want to know exactly I love that movie
right okay Batman vs Superman
can I have how many
other than 30 seconds it's my favorite
Martha why'd you say that name other
than that it's it's my favorite DC movie
I absolutely [ __ ] love it
um it's just that what would you say
that name but actually if they just
delete I just have to run out of the
room going when that bits on and then I
come back and enjoy the rest of the film
The Ends week to be fair
Suicide Squad
um overall
overall it's a really bad film I gotta
just go yeah it's it's one of those
things that's if you broke it up into a
series you'd be like two or three of
those episodes are good and two or three
of those episodes were terrible
um so they I think um David Eric could
have done well though
yep no air cut I'm not going for an air
cut but I I think
his actual vision would have been at
least better than what we got
um first Wonder Woman film
yay we agree on one look at that
um Justice League the original Justice
League and then we'll do the exact side
of things
we're doing a lot more films dancing
Aquaman
Jason Momoa
the actual film
ing
um Shazam
that's my thing I love Suzuki
okay fine whatever
birds of prey
did not see it
um okay this is the easiest one
Wonder Woman 1984.
I don't even have the energy to put my
thumbs down for that
yeah I just I just pooed myself a little
bit
I was the biggest disappointment was the
villain
which one they were all really
disappointed there's two or three in
those
that's what Taylor was just
and Pedro was just
yeah it's an assistant I mean his
performance was it was so I mean so he
has Mandalorian then he has Game of
Thrones those performances were just
through the roof awesome then it's like
well at that time he had the Mandalorian
out and he was also doing I believe it
was Robert Rodriguez's
superhero kid movie so he was in two
superhero films at the same time it was
a Netflix film I believe yeah yeah
infinitely better and it was just a
campy fun Spy Kids like
cheesy kids movie I forget the title uh
I think it's on Netflix too where he was
stranded on a planet
with this kid it's oh that is like a
2018 movie I haven't watched it yet but
I've only heard absolutely phenomenal
things yeah it's supposed to be
excellent
really good really it's just you know
just a two-person drama really of it is
really really good it's really simple it
was I literally watched it a couple
weeks ago and I can't remember it was
cool I think it's on Netflix here in the
UK at the moment I've heard a lot of
people reference that as the reason why
they think Pedro is going to do so good
in the last of us so it reminded me of
the black hole
that film in like tone
that's what it's sort of like
thing is and another film apparently
Disney are gonna remake okay The Suicide
Squad imagine at least titled
but whatever
yeah it's making the TV series is
brilliant
oh you've got it because I loved it
thesis on it it's just James Gunn it's
it's like Thor Ragnarok I mean not Thor
Ragnar excuse me Thor 11 Thunder with
too much taka that was too much James
Gunn there was literally a I think it
was a seven minute opening scene of him
falling out of that one apartment in
episode one or two or three and that was
the most dragged out I was it's
abhorrent for for that to be on a
television series
on and on and on I loved it it tickled
my childish brain is what it did
um
well made but I'm loving it
and I hated The Suicide Squad the sequel
I hated it I can't even remember big
chunks of it but when the giant squid
think I I hated it
um finger and eyeballs moment and then
obviously I'm sorry Prospect was the
other uh Pedro Pascal movie we were
talking about
sci-fi yeah it was 19 no it was that was
2018 not 19 2018. sorry right and then
obviously we're now on to Black Adam
but the future of DC at the moment is
we've got the Batman now which is not
really part of this universe they seem
to have separated themselves a little
promise now we've got two dceus
um they've got rid of the Batgirl movie
since the new
um people in charge of coming so David
zaslaf has come in as the new
um hey dude how you doing
um
as the new chief executive of Warner
Brothers Discovery and they have new
Chief Executives in charge of movies as
well in Pam Abdi and Mike Deluca of um
come over from MGM when MGM got bought
out by Amazon they were all this is
great two weeks later they were like we
want to leave and they left and they
went to Warner Brothers or they were
pushed and went to Warner Brothers
um
so there is all new people in charge
there is a new Direction
what does that mean for the DC and you
know another thing I'm thinking is that
the CW is moving away from the DC as
well
what does that mean but we'll we'll
contact first of all on the movies let's
talk about the Batgirl
translation they spent 18 million
dollars up to that point making that
film and then they just
cut its head off and they just they just
think they could have just spent another
10 million dollars finished it off and
just put it on HBO Max but they decided
not to do that
the the rumor being that the film was
just not in keeping with where they want
to take the DC in the future
I'd look forward you guys think about
that but for one how what do you think
about a new chief executive coming in
and doing something like that to a movie
that was 90 done
I kind of think it's shitty because
every time this really happened in the
pastor Studio new studio exec comes in
and you know wipes out a slate of films
because he doesn't like them he doesn't
see that as his vision of the future
Studio it's real it's shitty for the
artist and it's also shitty for the fans
because you know as you and I know
you know these decisions are mostly made
by marketing people
who have an advertising degree and not a
film degree don't they're not even
decent film critics they're just
marketing people and you know as
um
as it was written by Douglas Adams and
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
advertising people is one of the most
worthless people in the world
I mean just it's right there in the book
it's It Was Written yeah so anyway I
always find it disappointing you know
because uh
you know a lot of artists through work
just got flushed down the toilet and
we'll never see if we're good or for bad
you know
Brenton Fraser's
um role in that has been widely
acclaimed as brilliant and they're
saying that's the biggest shame that
we're not going to see that
but but harriswood what do you think
I'm the exact opposite I think it is
necessary I am happy zaslav is doing it
I think it's necessary for the whole
company as a whole I think it's good
how many thumbs down did we just have
going over two-thirds of the DC films
do we want to add more thumbs down to
all that list
into the ground
that's what they're doing that's what
they have been doing at least Walter
Hamada just left the company and I like
him as a creative individual I just
don't like anything that happened prior
to during and and what's happening even
post his his Mainstay with DC and Warner
Brothers
um
and the there's there's the the problem
I think there is that they don't it's
not the fact that they don't have a
Kevin feige it's the fact that they
don't even have a committee of people
that can agree on anything so we keep
getting these meddling films that try to
be about something and then they just
lose what's happening because of
producers and and uh Studio feedback
throughout the film it's there's not an
actual filmmaker's Vision I don't think
Snyder really ever had his full
filmmaker's vision I'm not opposed to
that I'm not the biggest snatter person
in the world I also like Zack Snyder's
Justice League significantly more than
the actual Justice League and I Watchmen
is one of my favorite if not my favorite
individual comic book film but Man of
Steel and Batman versus Superman there
were reasons my thumbs were down but
um
it's
they need fresh
not just content and all that I don't
even like referring to films as content
even though it's how they're treated
nowadays I
they need fresh everything and zazlov's
ax is
that that beautiful thing tearing
through all the [ __ ] and they're just
cleaning up house I I and it's not it
sucks for the Batgirl crew and cast as
an actor and someone who wants to direct
and produce and do all that
that that part hurts me but if if it
wasn't just as love the company itself
stated that they were not confident in
the film the whole company that means
the board anybody and everybody involved
they all had to unanimously agree to put
that out
which means that nobody liked that girl
movie and if it was a 90 million dollar
mishap that would have just tossed on
the HBO Max
the the way I guess the films and TV
shows are graded is not necessarily just
it is marketing in a way because the
only way Studios make money off of TV
shows or movies on a streaming services
bringing in new subscribers who is going
to be a new subscriber watching Batgirl
nobody all the people that would watch
it are probably already subscribed for
all the DC content it wouldn't have
brought anybody new and that was his
pivotal point they couldn't have made
money off of it if they released into
theaters and they couldn't have made
money off of it if they didn't release
him to theaters so I the the one that
hurts me the most is they
let go of the scoob and I'm a big
Scooby-Doo fan I'm I like weed what do
you expect a Shaggy Shaggy and scuba are
my heart and soul right there so I was
more disappointed in that they canceled
the Halloween Scooby-Doo movie than they
did the Batgirl film because at this
point
DC is their their heart blood
and it's no longer Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon is Warner Brothers
whether we say so or not that's how
they're actually making that that's the
only way they're marketing right now and
getting people to see things because how
many people are tuning in to house the
dragon every week a lot more than went
to go see Black Adam this week even
though Black Adam did better than a lot
of people expected it's kind of hit that
uh
meeting we expected it to but
to take a tax break I think it was very
mature and very reasonable Tuesday
am I reverberating a little bit no okay
uh I I think it was a reasonable thing
for zazlov and the company to just say
we're we're cutting it taking our losses
and we're going to make sure
all the next films that come out are
going to be thumb ups for you and not
come down not middling
I I would say bare minimum it was a
brave decision
to why 80 million or 90 million dollars
off the books I'm just saying that is
it's not good enough I'm sorry but it's
not good enough instead of doing maybe
what they did with Justice League you
can go in this is a mess but we'll bring
in somebody else and we'll just try to
fix it and then actually ended up just
making it worse so instead of spending
more money and they just went you know
what it doesn't matter how much money
we're going to spend throughout this
it's it's just not good enough oh and
they've already got enough PR stuff
going on with the flash right now where
they if they have to toss more money at
a film that they have to release that's
the one that they have to just go ahead
and
toss out because that's too much money
gone and Batgirl if if they if the flash
comes out and then Batgirl comes out
and
I mean the flash isn't it's supposed to
be a really good film I really hope I
appreciate it actually pulls it out but
no matter what we know Ezra Miller is
going to leave a bad taste in her mouth
is that same universe that same kind of
do we want that
right after that you know I guess take a
little break and then give us Aquaman
give us that big Blockbuster thing
that's going to distract us from the
fact that oh yeah Ezra was just hanging
out with everybody backstage over here
as well what do we think of bat woman in
CW
Ruby Rose uh what was it Bruce Wayne's
niece I think it was I watched three
episodes of the first season you mean
the TV season seriously yeah I hated it
I thought it was rubbish
it's gotten won four seasons belt by now
like I got three episodes in
and I couldn't watch it
um I just thought it was
boring after after I think after the
toward the end of the first season it
got dramatically better and then there
was a new Batwoman
um and I give second the second season a
try it was like it's kind of like Gotham
Gotham started off really really strong
and I thought
and then it just kind of you know with
the
um the season with the pig trying to
find out who the pig is it really kind
of lost a lot of its momentum
um another DC uh franchise that I think
is doing very well is not a CW Show it's
more of a I think it's HBO
uh is Penny worth the story of Alfred
the butler which is [ __ ] excellent
still excellent
maybe I should have given back girl a
little bit more of a chance
I just didn't I didn't add you know it's
one of those things isn't it all shows
are not
it happened so often that shows aren't
great at the beginning but they find
their feet you should always try to give
a new season a new series up to I think
about like episode 10 or 12 until you
actually make a decision on it
but I just disliked it so much I just
couldn't bring myself to watch it I
think it's more you're watching other
things aren't you but I feel bad now
that I didn't give a chance
they have done some there has been some
really I'm I don't mean to be the the
guy that's sticking it for DC here but
Arrow did very well you know over
multiple Seasons uh Smallville I think
is the one that really kicked it off for
uh
did very well it was just
sometimes man the [ __ ] they put out just
don't work
and and late and most of that's been
lately I mean during the Smallville days
is like they could do no they could do
no wrong and now it's like
yeah
and then there's link which was really
good I thought you know at least for the
first couple Seasons I haven't seen
anything past the first couple Seasons
but it was really good
I just to go back to the like Man of
Steel so we've talked about the movies
up till now and what we've
I genuinely really liked Man of Steel I
um I thought it was a bit I I know it's
a bit more Clark Kent
than Superman
and it was a different slightly
different take on Superman but why did
you hate it so much
either Harrison really hate it come on
why did you really hate it
is pompous
well what you just said you just said it
was more Clark Kent than Superman
yeah when
when was he actually Clark Kent in that
movie or was he just Zack Snyder's
embodiment of just normal reporter dude
that has a pompous he was not Clark Kent
that was not Clark Kent and that was not
Superman that was a whole different
character entirely that was that was and
and sure I I will always say different
directors have different Visions going
into something and each each person
doing that is going to add a different
embodiment to what whatever actor they
choose to put into that role
but how was your investor when a car can
I I don't know it sure I mean I I have
issues with the way Snyder handled his
DCU stuff
I don't dis dislike a lot of it at its
core and in its eye idea phase but I
just don't think it translated well from
the idea phase to the actual on-screen
phase
Henry Cavill is my favorite Superman so
I I say that with not liking any of the
things he's really been in as Superman
besides maybe Zack Snyder's Justice
League he's just absolutely perfect in
the role and he he is he is Superman
but none of the things he's played have
given me reason to believe that and if
he actually had played Superman or Clark
Kent I don't think we would be getting
faceless cameos in half the post-credit
scenes he's in I don't think we could
get him as a faceless cameo in half the
movie season
thankfully The Rock brought him back at
the post-credits scene for Black Adam
but it kind of talks how to talk into at
one point Henry Cavill anymore yeah six
years
that's why he's not in Shazam it's not
because they didn't want him to they
were arguing over a contract wouldn't
they and he stood up around him Cavill
for a little bit sort of went well I'm
not doing it then
um but luckily now they've seen sense
and gotten to sign a a respectful
contract
um but
I wasn't weren't they just trying to
show a Superman though that was
struggling with
the the the thing of that he was an
alien on Earth I know the whole thing
with his dad in bit with Kevin Costner
was a bit Kevin Costner would rather die
than take the risk of one or two people
seeing Superman like shoot across it
that that was a bit stupid but um but
was it I I thought they were just trying
to look at a slightly different
perspective on the character as a movie
I enjoyed it I don't get me wrong
Spider-Man Superman 2 with Christopher
Reeve was much better take on the whole
Zodi thing
um
yeah exactly and the whole glass
that was fantastic but um
I I it's a horrible I really enjoyed the
movie I love the fight scene at there I
thought the special effects in the fight
scene were fantastic it looks amazing
it looks absolutely amazing I'm I'm just
very I don't look around the surface
Stone and I go this looks pretty I like
this it's pretty good and I'm not don't
worry about anything else
one movie is way too fast
yeah I just sit there eating popcorn
I like this
ever you know the whole like I see dead
people movie The Sixth Sense didn't see
the twist coming I was just sat there
enjoying the movie everyone else went oh
I saw it coming halfway through and I'm
like
Man of Steel for the same sort of
reasons just pompous
I mean it was it was like um
I don't want to use the word preachy but
um
it was I'm not saying it was woke don't
just keep your panties on right it was
just uh
it was just office I mean like like like
Harris said which was perfect
was that really Clark Kent was Clark
Kent actually Superman at any point I
mean just it's just you know and
it went so far afield of what Superman
supposed to be
I mean it could have been Superman
parallel universe 1487 or whatever you
know I was just it just didn't it it
just I I I like the trailers at the
beginning of the movie then I did the
movie itself
I said it I'm not going to retract it I
don't care what you say
Mister
wow I prefer the trailers for 99 of
movies I watched so
um okay Batman vs Superman though other
than the why'd you say that name uh [ __ ]
me I hate that it's still genuinely if I
understood that what is one of the worst
scenes in a movie ever was a bug fly
mode
what are you doing okay sorry I planted
right over my microphone
I saw a thing once you're saying the
worst scenes in a movie ever and there
was this like James Coburn movie years
ago and it was um because you murdered a
man no self-defense because you robbed a
man I was taking when I was owed because
you raped a woman there's assault with a
friendly weapon and it was generally
considered one of the worst lines in a
movie ever I would say why do you say
that name is up there with that it was
such a bad moment and it generally made
me like throw up a little bit in my
mouth when it happened and there was but
the annoying thing was there were so
many other ways they could have done
that
any other way
let me let me give you another reason
why this show was really defective
Jesse Eisenberg is Lex Luthor
I didn't mind
I love the idea of it but once again the
execution
does Lex is Lex Luthor I mean come
across as the kind of individual that'd
be a sniveling millennial
really no you do have a good point on
that it comes across almost insane
doesn't he like he's I mean
bad casting choice I mean it was just
that's the bad the Facebook dude really
um Rosenbaum from
um did a much better job
yeah
sorry what and then they should have
made I mean Jeremy Irons would have made
any kind of random villain much more
villainous but no he's Alfred the kind
and and coordinated and competent Alfred
yeah but the fight scenes were cool
the window and beats everybody up was
cool
okay I'm trying to defend again I feel
like I have the same
not I can't say hatred I got I gotta
preface this for all the Zack Snyder
people because they're gonna come
crucify me I Watchmen might be my
favorite superhero film there is now
that being said Batman vs Superman which
is like people are like oh that's such a
great film you just don't understand it
no Zack Snyder doesn't understand what
he was trying to do once again like Man
of Steel
he you're as a director to add a
perspective to these characters you're
supposed to add a perspective to the
characters that has not seen been seen
before and this dude just made a whole
bunch of new characters and put people's
names on it so we would put our asses in
seats and pay a ticket for it he did not
make a movie that was Batman he did not
make a movie that was Superman none of
those characters were actually the the
theirs are decades worth of materials
Batman's in the 30s we're in the 20s
right now that's 90 years of material
that's almost a century and
the Batman that I've seen is not the
same guy I did here it is he wants to
kind of bring it in a more Spacey and
not so like
Detective Comics private like staying on
that ground level it's good to see
Batman and the whole big wide world
and there it is Harris Cuts clean to the
Bone
it's just you know he's it gets right
yeah that was a perfect perfect
summation Harris perfect you should run
you should realize and I hate DC even
more than I thought I did I've always
liked these I always think they make but
I dislike DC for the movies that we're
going to talk about in a minute and bits
but I've always thought the DC films
that casting is always perfect
whoever's their casting director is a
genius thing oh he's getting on Jason
Momoa and Justice in in sorry in Aquaman
is is just perfect for it I hate that
film it's not very good
um
well well yeah so I bet with everything
to my Johnny
um
yeah
right
um I I have absolutely no memory of
Amber Heard in that film I don't give a
fly and
um and they're cutting out oh God you're
glaring yeah you got blurry
you put some Vicks over your lenses
there we go the autofocus burped I think
sorry uh that pissed me sometimes
um but um yeah it's just completely
forgettable the bad man in and and and
Aquaman's completely forgettable the
only thing that I thought was really
good the opening sequence on the
submarine actually thought was pretty
cool and Yaya's performance at least was
great in that Yaya abdoma team doesn't
not give a great performance the rest of
the movie
yeah and the whole thing with the Mantis
thing was just it just looked ridiculous
the one thing that Marvel are good at is
they take like the comic book and they
just sort of like tone it down and
change it slightly and while they have
been good until last couple of films
they change it slightly and just make it
a bit this side of stupid
that they didn't bother they just
basically recreated the comic and it
just looked it just looked ridiculous
um that's just that they did a really
bad job with it but Jason Momoa is so
good in it people seem to not notice
that the film was awful people didn't
notice anything else except Jason Momoa
sorry yeah including me God that man's
gorgeous did I tell you the story I met
him once in an elevator did I tell you
the story no you did not used to met
everybody though but go on when did you
mean okay so I'm in dragging con right
and I'm coming down the elevator to the
main uh main Auditorium and there is
this Roar
this Roar of Screams what the [ __ ] is
going on is somebody getting like
murdered or something and they're the
doors open right there's this giant mats
of meat called Jason Momoa and there is
about 50 girls dressed as Bo Peep I
think it was screaming
his name and then he he had this
expression of total
exasperation flusteredness embarrassment
as as you could see this weighted Soul
getting onto the elevator from being
tormented by the screams of multiple Bo
peeps
unless there's some uh manga character
that is also looks exactly like Bo Peep
and that could have been it but I swear
to God they had the whole Crook and the
whole thing is
trying to catch all over it it could
have been from that werewolf movie he
was in I should know it off the top of
my head it wasn't all that great but it
was his big thing after Stargate That
was supposed to get him into the film
franchises but he ended up HBO thank you
for Game of Thrones this is like 2014
2015. yeah no that it was right around
then it could have been his
lycanthrope film for for lack of
knowledge
I knew he was going to be a big star as
soon as he was in when he was in stock
Atlantis so it was so clear it was going
to be a big star because he's got that
cheeky green and and everything it's
just like
yeah I knew it was going to be a big
start I was right after he is right
after a Game of Thrones yeah there you
go so that that's would have been it so
just as he was becoming massive really
yeah
um if we move off of that I think Shazam
for me is a Kids film but it's good it's
entertaining
I don't I didn't hate it
the first Wonder Woman I thought was
great but again why did they make it
after suicide squad and why didn't they
make it before Batman vs Superman
why did they make why is it like the
fifth movie or sixth fourth movie in the
list it should have been the second
movie in the list and Aquaman should
have been in the third movie they made
all these films Aquaman should never
have come out after Justice League oh
well wasn't there a problem with that
um
hang on a second you know what we'll
solve it all the acts of zaslov
really at least he did seem to be
um but I said they just they just I just
don't understand why they had to
why they had to shoot their load with
Justice League what kind of what's been
going on with them since the beginning
though since there's a production
problems with Joss Whedon
there's always a book with Snyder first
Snyder's was it I think it was his
daughter because his wife is still his
producing partner but his daughter died
uh I believe she committed suicide it
was really sad which is why he had to
stop justice league in the studio was
like yeah we can't wait on you
get Josh Whedon and then we go he wasn't
even though it wasn't that they would
refuse to he basically said he refused
to come back and I'm not doing it didn't
he and he he he was almost like I
retired sort of thing he was but he just
lost his son or his daughter so you're
right yeah I'm pretty sure it just
committed suicide so this dude I mean he
deserves as much as I poo poo on the
some of the stuff more recent more
recent I like all of his older stuff but
more recent just just
I I don't know who's to blame for that I
just think it's two completely different
directions and they and it just seemed
to be you know I just end up being a
mess that's kind of the issue with the
whole DC in EU in general is this the
the studio and all the producers behind
it they they have not been able to have
a Clear Vision there wasn't just like of
course Marvel's got through Kevin feige
so that's always easy just to bring it
back to but typically you have your
committee that are like all right so
this is what we're doing these are our
rules we have a guy that's holding on to
like all of our Allure and they're the
one piecing the canonical aspect of
things together
did they have a lore guy it didn't seem
like they had a lore guy you know which
everybody does it seems to me that
there's like there's some basic mistakes
going on there in the DC though that
like when they have the Justice League
movie which is their big Avengers film
but at that point at least two of the no
three of the Justice League we've not
seen them before
we have not seen half of the team
before that we've not seen cyborg we've
not I was doing briefly but it was in a
different actor wasn't it it came
through the don't trust him but uh yeah
we've not seen The Flash and we've not
seen Aquaman
it's half the freaking team that's just
that's just an error
um
just now maybe getting a Flash movie you
know how many years later
it should have come before just they had
no build up to the Justice League they
just sort of went oh we'll just do it
and it's like No it should there was no
there's just that they just tried to
jump to the end
it's just a basic decision error from
the top as far as I'm concerned
you know it's just
but and then they made Wonder Woman 1984
and I actually generally thought that
was the end of DC which is one of the
main reasons why I said we're you know
we're having this conversation I thought
it was done
after that
well there's a reason everything
afterwards was supposed to be a day in
day out with HBO Max as well
yeah I think I think if we if concerning
Wonder Woman and why it was out of place
I think remember they originally got
Joss Whedon to write the screenplay he
was originally because he'd just come
off of the uh Avengers
high but it went as I understand in some
of the reporting behind it it went
really bad off track and they scrapped
the whole thing and that may be why it
was out of sync because they spent a lot
of time with Whedon developing that
script and you just type Google John
Sweden Wonder Woman you will see all
sorts of
disparaging remarks to say it politely
but I think that would I think the
reason it was postponed to push back is
because
they were originally going to go with
Whedon I mean the the Observer called it
the sexist Wonder Woman screenplay
it's definitely when his problem started
wasn't it it was and they started to
become public anyway
but if you look at everything after
Shazam they had Birds of Prey World
Wonder Woman 1984 The Suicide Squad
um
Am I Wrong to have had that opinion
really that the DC would done
I I I think they could come back it's
just you know once the marketing guys
stop [ __ ] around with it I think
it'll be better it's just like you know
marvel I just showed you a book full of
Marvel characters
you know there's lots of content there
there's lots of stories there it's just
are they willing to do what they need to
do
to fix it tell the story and and for a
love of God get away from Batman and
Superman I mean yeah I appreciate the
Joker the movie that came out that was
the Joker you know it was okay but
[Music]
I didn't actually enjoy it as a movie
particularly but I appreciated what they
were trying to do with it I I from like
a critical point of view I I always
think there's a difference between
respect in a movie and enjoying a movie
sometimes and the joke I respected
didn't it didn't particularly entertain
me Batman vs Superman I found
entertaining as hell but yeah if I break
it down I'd maybe don't respect it as a
movie The reason I liked it the most was
because of its uh because of its
treatment of mental illness
because this treatment what so I missed
that mental illness uh one of the things
he's on the bus and he's got a card that
says you know he gives it to the kid and
I thought I thought that was really
strong because it's
um
I remember I I had I saw a scene like
that in real life once upon a time when
I was living in San Francisco kid really
um
not mentally ill but he he was
definitely disadvantaged mentally and a
lot of the people on the bus
unfortunately was really against the kid
called the cops the whole nine yards
then lo and behold the his uncle was
sitting on the on the seat on the
opposite side of the bus just watching
all this unfold and they had this bus
and it was just like really the kid is
definitely in it
for me because I I'd seen that before
and I saw how the crowd
in a town like San Francisco it's
supposed to be kind of understanding or
miscible just [ __ ] wasn't
I mean the cops got I mean it was a
whole scene you know picking on this
mentally disadvantaged kid
the [ __ ] and then I saw it in the Joker
and I said yeah I've seen that and so
that's one reason why I appreciate
especially his uh his performance
because he really I thought did it well
now killing somebody on a television
show okay that's maybe a little bit too
much but you know at least I I
appreciated that it it it it didn't make
um
mental illness a joke
in my real life I work in mental illness
I work in adult social care I should say
and I I come in contact with mental
illness and personality disorders a
great deal so you can again I respect
that it's one of the reasons why though
I want movies to entertain me and not
necessarily because my real life is
quite stressful and quite challenging
working with people to get them into the
community so they sort of actually
seeing people that do have challenges
like that becomes normal there's a is a
big
thing that we're trying to do and trying
to push forwards because it's it's not
at the moment people see somebody with
Asperger's or something and they just
think they're they still unfortunately
go weirder and we have to try to but the
only way to get around that is to get
people in the community and get them so
that they're a part of the community and
then when you come in contact with these
people and it becomes more normal and
hopefully people will start seeing them
as remembering to see them as human
beings instead of the condition and
that's what I'm saying but that's one of
the reasons why I want my movies just to
be entertain me I think because my real
life is so so serious I then don't want
to watch serious movies when I come home
um so I can respect the Joker but it
doesn't necessarily entertain me I
wouldn't watch it again I think he's a
is what I'm trying to say I feel sorry
are you intrigued with Foley I do
um
and and thingy is um as Harley Quinn as
musical Lady Gaga Harley Quinn not at
least intriguing no
I'll end up watching it at some point
but I'm not in is remotely excited by
that
oh but
again I'm sure they'll do something I
I'm not sure I can't quite see where
they're going to go with it I thought
the first one
it was powerful
and it was and I like say I respect the
hell out of it I don't see where they're
going with it next I don't know how they
can pick because if they pick up or
they're just doing a second one they
have to pick it up from somewhere and
where exactly are they picking it up
from the first Joker is very purposeful
in
what how did it actually end you know I
mean we obviously get the whole car
scene and him on top of everything but
then we also cut right back to the
hospital so we don't know exactly what's
going on we don't know what was we know
something's in his head but we just
don't know how much or what was in his
head and or where he is at as a person
and I guess they're gonna have to
explore that but
does that mean everything in the film
happened does that mean 90 of the things
in the film a little who knows you know
is it even the Joker we know from the
comics or is it just is that just the
name of the that's uh yeah it lost me in
places after him it's I I don't know how
it's gonna fit
in how does the Batman
fit in with DC because that was another
reason why I thought well this is the
end of DC now or the dceu we were coming
used to because they completely went
like we give up on Batman we've been
making a completely new movie a movie
that's torn people up I actually
personally loved it but I need to I want
to watch it again I watch at the cinema
and it is quite long I want to watch it
again before I have like a a proper
decision on it but I actually quite
liked it
um
but I thought that was another nail in
the coffee and I said well they're going
off in completely different direction
but but as Black Adam saved it
oh you're cutting out a little bit Jay
oh I've still got you fine
oh
right
God damn you right
um same watermelon
this is really the point of the video
has Black Adam saved that universe
what what's Universe what universe so
everything that we've seen up till now
man of steel blah blah blah all these
films
I don't think black Adam's in that
universe
I and that's a lot to put on the
shoulders of Black Adam man that that's
that's but Dwayne Johnson did that on
purpose though
he wants that to be there big shoulder
yeah but yeah I don't think I I think
um
Dwayne Johnson's role goal was to make
it a really good interesting
non-formulaic kind of show that's not
Batman or Superman but saving the DC
Universe that's a lot I don't think
that's where he
that he did well I don't think he he has
that kind of studio power even though he
is Dwayne Johnson well he did one thing
there's one action that he took and made
sure happen that kind of uh juxtaposes
that thought completely
the fact that Henry Cavill is now
Superman again because not only did he
come Henry I mean Dwayne The Rock
Johnson made sure that not only is Henry
Cavill going to be able to show his face
but if he shows his face what's that
mean he needs another film and they've
confirmed that Henry Cavill is getting
another Superman film so he is typically
saving what we know as the dceu but I'm
still not convinced I don't think
Aquaman or Wonder Woman exists in the
same world as Zack Snyder's Justice
League or Justice League either one I
think they're gonna go retroactively
just say
no no no and put it put those where they
want it to be I think now I think I
think Black Adam is going to be our
not ground floor and not our Cornerstone
or anything like that but it's going to
at least help them start to rebuild I
don't know if they necessarily actually
have a Cornerstone or like proper
framework
um to to build a house off of you know
is my metaphor here but
it wasn't for Black Adam and it will be
successful
if it wasn't for Black Adam I think we
wouldn't have seen Henry Cavill we
wouldn't have seen but I know there's
another Wonder Woman movie coming but I
think it would have been the last one
and I think they would in Aquaman too we
probably would have wouldn't have seen
that again they would have put it back
now it feels like they've got an
opportunity but I think I'm with you
Harris I think they'll pick and choose
now over sort of almost like what's
Canon so they'll go okay Wonder Woman
1984 let's never mention that again
um Justice League we just won't mention
it again different Multiverse that's all
you got to say
exactly a cyborg
um you know we're going to see The Flash
movie
um we're potentially going to see
um thinking as Batman again now
um uh Ben Affleck is Batman again in The
Flash movie
um even even though he said I'm never
doing it again these are terrible he
seems to have won well Ben Affleck is in
the Aquaman too I believe so yeah
Michael Keaton's in the flash right
is supposed to be in the flash as well
they're going to have well the one room
was they were gonna have multiple
Batmans okay okay Michael Keaton was
also in Batgirl
yeah
so he was gonna be the only thing that
kept that glue together there apparently
yeah but um yeah so that that is one but
that's where the Ben Affleck
here's a question here's a question
well first I'd like to start off with
the statement that clearly Marvel had
their World building ideas
much better plan than DC did you know
now and also
um
DC
doesn't have Disney money neither does
Warner
they don't have Disney money they don't
have I mean I'm still waiting for a
coherent streaming service for Warner
Brothers but you know we get all these
that's another topic
and so clearly you know DC is suffering
from any kind of overarching
you know uh plan to
to show all of their properties it's
just it seems like it's scatter shot you
know and one thing I think that they've
missed because they keep going to the
same damn well
one thing that they've missed is if
we're going to do completely doing uh
Batman Batman and Batman and shows how
about Gotham by Gaslight which I thought
was originally really original uh take
on Batman
um back in Victorian times you know and
it was very original very well done
really you know you could shoot that as
almost as a one-off and not really [ __ ]
with Canon that much
I don't think there's and Jay you
probably know more than I do I don't
think there's any plans to ever made
Gotham by Gaslight into a film or God
it'd make a tremendous series though
Jesus they do an animated or are they
going to do an animated
was awesome
you guys seen that the Animated Series
Batman right this is 20 years oh yeah
Batman the Animated Series is great I
grew up with all that which is why I'm
so hard on DC yeah okay so well yeah I
mean true you know because I this this
current iteration of what they're trying
to do with DC's you know uh
it's like so hit and miss it's like
there was more planning that went into
Legions of tomorrow than there did the
entirety of the other DC verse you know
well you said it well a second ago it's
obviously none of the DC people have got
together and put a plan together and a
plan with future plans that Kevin [ __ ]
did mm-hmm
but wait a second Kevin fagi wasn't the
first person to do this he learned from
DC animation he learned from Marvel
animation prior to that he learned from
when Marvel tried to do this way back in
the day he learned from the first actual
Cinematic Universe that we had on our
screens were the Christmas movies back
in the day the stop-motion Christmas
movies with Rudolph and the little elf
guy and all father time and all that
stuff
exactly there's more planning that goes
into Cheetos flavors for the next four
years and has gone into DC just saying
the big difference that the son's life
has come out and said we've got a plan
for the next 10 years
with the DC
and that's one of the things you said
with with Batgirl Batgirl didn't fit
that that 10-year plan
um The Rock Dwayne Johnson has come out
and said there's a plan there's going to
be Black Adam vs Superman it's not going
to be something that's going to be I
think this is this is going to be a slow
burn towards them
fight them but there is a plan
um and that is the difference isn't it
but Kevin FEI to me always seemed to be
his plan was to simplify and it was sort
of like let's not and that that's so
this is on to my last question in the
evening because my stomach's crumbling
um
Marvel has definitely taken a little bit
of a nosedive recently everything seems
to be overly complicated
and they're trying to do too many
different things and the what I always
felt was like say Marvel's
um
most important bit was that they were or
they're the thing they did best because
they kept being simple they kept things
entertaining and they kept things that
it all made sense and that all seems to
have gone a bit Spaghetti Junction in
the last couple of years so that's a
British thing and because we have a road
system this country called Spaghetti
Junction it's the most confusing
freaking road on the planet all these
roads go in and they don't seem to go
anywhere if we have one of those in
Atlanta
oh yeah yeah but um that's it I'm glad
that's just saying that travels
um but the Marvel system could the DC
actually then take advantage of that
over the next few years if they release
a couple of movies if the flash is good
if the new Wonder Woman movie is good if
Aquaman 2 could they actually
it's always been sort of like Marvel's
poor cousin the DC movies they're always
been a bit second right could they
actually overtake their uh
loud neighbors and become you know the
dominant force in Superior movies in the
next few years if they play their cards
around
do you think they'd risk that kind of
money
they can make a lot of money I can't
make a lot of money on Batman movies
alone how is it like in the top 20
movies of all time highest grossing
moves or something like three of them
Batman films
no
the highest oh I'm okay I'm thinking uh
well either way uh no Marvel's and
Disney in general has that entire list
the top 10 films ever made I think
Disney is every single one of them maybe
besides one because at least domestic
box office us wise I know Disney has the
Marvel has I think four out of the first
like six and then Star Wars The Last
Jedi and Star Wars the Force awakens are
up there
oh I tell you what actually you are bang
on
I'm down to 40 something I still haven't
found about my movie
Batman definitely you definitely used to
be in the top 10 highest grossing movies
of all time Mojo cop lifetime Grocers
avatars number one Avatar uh
Spider-Man Jurassic World The Lion King
Avengers Furious 7 Top Gun Frozen 2
Avengers black panther Harry Potter Star
Wars just yeah these are all Disney
movies Beauty and the Beast Incredibles
Fast and the Furious
Iron Man 3. first a lot of couple though
Jurassic 25 Aquaman number 25. okay oh
cause Aquaman made 1.2 billion or
something like that we looked it up I
think
I've lost it now
but no no you brought up a good point
I'm sorry what the Dark Knight was
number 50.
ah
well I guess so ignore me completely
wrong Batman vs Superman 78
Panda 2 was 146.
I'm just wondering if this is just
American or what have I actually picked
up there no highest growth for IMDb Pro
yeah
so there you go they'll always make
about my movies don't they they'll
always make Superman movies but is the
wider DC Universe I I just feel like
they're in a better position right now
than Marvel I think I just feel like
Marvel's very confused
well okay
that is
you bring up two interesting points
because you were saying stormy a minute
ago was like no Batman no Superman focus
on all these this wide plethora of
characters which you know not a bad idea
Black Adam one of the things I thought
that they have DC in general has kind of
been doing but been doing weaker is just
kind of tossing us into a world of
superheroes without like saying okay
superheroes exist this is what's going
on this is the particular individual
story we're going over
which is a great concept but I don't
think they've been doing it very well
Shazam and Black Adam which is kind of
funny because you know they're both
shazams in their own way I think those
have done that by far the best within
that world that they have but all that
being said
not having Batman versus not not Batman
versus Superman but not having Batman
and Superman they're two they're Captain
America and Iron Man
I think is truly hurting them as a brand
and is not letting those other
characters they need the money to to be
able to fund those other characters and
those are the two characters they can
use to do that and that's not the only
reason to put those guys up there
they're great characters with great
stories but what happened with feige and
phase four
Once Captain America and Iron Man were
out
it didn't go all go to [ __ ] but it uh
the quality level has particularly
dropped since then
and characters like Miss Marvel I think
is where Marvel started to lose its way
because one of the things was that
Marvel was always quite grounded Iron
Man was still a man
um Captain America okay super serum but
he was still a man yeah it was a
grounding to it that that is one of the
problems with Superman and characters
like Captain Marvel they're too powerful
I'm Black Adam in a way they're too
powerful
um so how do you make a you know part of
the thing about making a movie and
having a bit of
um dread to it or you know is is that is
that human weakness or the or the idea
that they could lose and it's like all
of a sudden there's like there's none of
that was super funny just
and the Justice League is a prime
example of that they were battling and
about to lose by Superman turned up and
just basically punched a bad guy in the
face and that was it done
as an offshoot comparing all this DC you
know they don't know what they're doing
what did you guys think of uh on the
movie Unbreakable from like 20 years ago
22 years ago
huh
M night shyamalans yeah yeah yeah what
did you think about that because I
thought it was really interesting take
on superheroes the the origin story of
like two guys
kind of at odds with each other and I
thought it was really well known I
thought it was genius yeah
why can't we get more of that I guess is
my point you know with all the stuff do
you want more of that after we got split
though I'm not split I love split sorry
but afterwards terrible
how did they go from split to glass
see I really like glass on a conceptual
bullet point thing but once again just
the execution I was so excited about it
because I was just like this makes so
much sense this movie is going to be and
maybe this is the easiest film in the
world to make and they just it was [ __ ]
I just didn't mean it doesn't understand
it Sarah Sarah Paulson became the main
character out of nowhere and
a far harder movie to make
and from a conceptual point of view so
difficult to make and be good
the main reason why they got the right
actor and this is
phenomenal absolutely phenomenal third
one bloody awful that's good
um I quite liked the um Sylvester
Stallone movie that was on Amazon a
couple of weeks ago um premiere
the what sir what was it called The
Samaritan the Samaritan I really like
that this is similar I felt that was a
similar sort of feel too unbreakable
special effects because it was made for
director TV and what have you but it you
know it was maybe its aspiration was a
little bit higher than the money they
were willing to put into it but um I
felt that was a similar sort of um
some feel to the first unbreakable but
for me unbreakable was possibly way
ahead of its time it was just
um it was such a good idea
I think that would have been even more
popular if they'd made that film about
10 years later when you know when when
Marvel were really hitting there stride
and and and superhero movies with as you
know as stupidly popular as they become
and I think there's a I think we're
getting a bit of fatigue now but then
that film would have had such a much
impact
I feel like unbreakable did what DC's
been trying to do since
I was almost dead The Dark Knight but
since I guess Snyder's DC in general
because it's just trying to take so much
more of a grounded and dark tone and
yeah Dark Knight trilogy did that but
that was like
Ultra realism where nobody was actually
a hero it was all capable within the
tech that we have today where of course
everything after that is a little more
Super Hero in their own way but it was
very grounded and realistic kind of like
unbreakable and I feel like they they
tried to do that and just they didn't
fail they almost worse than failed
because it wasn't just so bad that all
right this is done let's try something
else we're like enough people liked it
let's keep pitter-pattering for the next
decade and that's just kind of what
we've been getting and and well one
thing I'd like to pick up on what you
said Harris is to further expand on it
um
The Dark Knight came out
right when America was In the Heat of uh
Iraq and Afghanistan I mean yeah 2008 I
mean you know uh 911 it was just seven
years earlier so now we're in a world
especially when the terrorists take over
New York Bain takes over New York
Batman Begins With 05 yeah yeah and so
it's like oh yeah that's uh
been there done that seen it and it had
a I think that gave it a completely
maybe different flavor for the script
writing than
what they may have originally entailed
because it was written like you said
more realistically more you know
yeah rise it definitely had an impact
because of the politics of the time more
than if you watched it now if somebody
you know a millennial watching it now
doesn't understand what what what well
even even here in the UK
you know 911 had a massive impact and I
think that
felt that that there was a shock wave
that went through that that
and you felt it in that movie
um
that maybe you don't appreciate looking
back on it now but
even at that time DC in general right
then was
I don't know if they were trying to bite
off more than they could chew but they
had two different projects 2005 was
Batman Begins which was that darker and
grittier more very grounded very
realistic but they tried to do the exact
opposite the next year with bat or not
Batman Begins uh with Superman Begins
right no no with with uh um Superman
Returns with uh there we go that's it
they tried to make a Christopher Reeve
sequel they tried to make it that fun
Boy Scout we've got hope which was kind
of not so much in in the I guess public
conscience at the time uh I think that
films aged a little bit better I I
prefer that over Man of Steel sorry but
yeah
I think I might prefer over Man of Steel
as well actually
I thought he was unfortunate really I
think they tried again
too much into the Christopher Reeve
movies
with his costume and everything they
went they went together
its biggest issue was the fact that it
didn't have a New Perspective at all
where Man of Steel was like okay instead
of A New Perspective same character just
screw the character New Perspective in
general that was like oh this is that
exact same character we're not going to
change too much so you know who he is
and it's like all right well we as an
audience know who he is already so you
had to add a little bit of a level a
little bit of depth to that character
for us to actually want to go back again
and they just didn't do that as well
yeah yeah I think that's fair
that goes well that was an interesting
debate
hour and a half
did we save the DCU
no I think
good okay um
I just no the problem is now we've got
we've got the MCU as we have still got a
coherent Multiverse
thing going on in DC now you've got
Batman which is one universe but I mean
they're leaning into it don't they
they're not even pretending they're like
yeah
too much into that because I can do a
whole nother video just on that you got
you think Snyder fans are gonna be mad
at me after this one the the Reeves fans
won't be very happy with me either if we
start talking about that
fair enough I think we're gonna have
three or four different Batmans on the
go very shortly anyway so yeah hey why
not it's probably my favorite character
in all of if you actually had to pick a
character out of DC though as a favorite
oh God I can't believe I'm asking this
now I want to go and get some tea oh I
already have one who's your favorite
who's your favorite DC character edrigan
the demon
the demon
okay how about you stormy do you have a
favorite
had to pick one I'm thinking
for me it's Batman I was not Batman
it's just cool
blue Beetle's great as well but oh oh
you know when you first I would say uh
Batwoman
um
primarily there was a there's an
animated uh show some years ago the
mysteries of the Batwoman I think it was
and let me look at it make sure I get
the
title correct
David is just trying to mention the best
Batman fixing I've ever heard is on
radio where Batman breaks his back and
some friends dude
Batman mystery of uh the Batwoman
and uh here comes some spoilers you know
Batman's trying to figure out who
Batwoman is and so was it her no it
can't be her because that's all her at
this thing and there was about what it
was it was actually there was three bat
women so oh it was so I think you know
in terms of a spoil to uh Batman
you know
um
a lot of people saw Catwoman you know
the spoiled Batman you know the the
smart uh woman you know she's a little
bit [ __ ] crazy that woman however
didn't have the
um
the homicidal Tendencies shall we say of
Catwoman
[Music]
um
do you like Batman's my favorite though
it comes down to two reasons the first
Batman movie with Michael Keaton
um before we had Sky TV and everything
in the UK we only really had four
channels and BBC one obviously world
renowned BBC One the movie on Christmas
Day on BBC One was a big deal back then
you know it was like everybody sat down
to watch whatever the big Premiere was
on BBC One and the one year it was the
first Batman movie
and they had um they used to do all
these little Cuts I don't have to do it
in America but between TV shows because
they didn't have adverts they would have
little animations between the TV shows
and the back year it was sort of like
mountains and clouds and a moon and that
was like their little pretty animation
between all the different shows
but but for the start of the Batman
movie they had the same animation
but then they had the Bat Plane come up
and like just pierce it was like
silhouetted on the moon and then back
down again and I would have been about
nine or ten that had such an impact on
me I was just like this is the greatest
thing ever and then obviously I love the
movie and Jack Nichols is Ace in it and
everything and I feel like that
kick-started what we now know is the
superhero genre you know it was just it
was probably getting a load of me
Batman Returns not so good I won't lie
and all the other Batman movies yeah
but the real reason
is that the animated series was so good
and the animated movie since have been
so good DC cannot make a movie to save
their lives but my God they can make an
animated movie The Batman Superman
Samurai thing they did a couple of years
ago that should have been awful but it
was Bloody brilliant they did basically
like a manga movie with Batman in
and I was like this is freaking awesome
it didn't really have an end the end was
a bit weak but it was freaking awesome
you know you just want to go out and
kill bad people when you watch it
afterwards
and I'm going to go and kill some bad
people you know it's just like I [ __ ]
love it that's why Batman's the coolest
and you know what's his superpower he's
rich
what is your favorite iteration of
Batman there's ever been
It's gotta be Michael Keaton
so what about animated is that your live
answer yeah this is the original
animated series was uh the best but
again that stands just time it's still
good now
but again I was at the right age so when
that came out first time around we used
to sit around and wait for it to
Premiere because we couldn't obviously
no streaming I think we had to wait for
it so there was so much anticipation and
it was just so damn good but then Batman
Beyond was excellent as well
Batman Begins is just
ah to me very fantastic because Batman
but he's known Michael Keaton
Batman Begins the animated series or is
there am I crazy Batman Beyond the one
with Terry McGinnis
when it's the future one it's the next
Batman Generations Batman Beyond well is
that's what it's called over here anyway
um but I love the Batwing and the plane
and everything I just thought it was
growing that's another show that
shouldn't have been any good it should
have been a lot of rubbish
stick
but it was basically the same people
that made the Batman animated series
they came on and did that and they said
like let's do the next bit and let's not
forget in the Animated Series Mark
Hamill is the Joker yeah well he's been
for years and think thank you thank you
Mark Hamill yeah he's
um
Batman what's that Batman and Superman
Battle of the super Sons trailer
I hate this stuff they keep doing this
don't they this is that a real thing
I've missed that if it is
um
kids
fighting yeah God that's probably a
thing I've not seen it but it's probably
a thing
um Ace you can tell us whether that's a
real thing or not but anyway guys it's
been an absolute pleasure having you on
as always
um thank you thank you I kind of dropped
you in on this one because we're going
to talk about something completely
different but then I watched
Black Adam yesterday we're doing
something else on your starting these
review are remotely prepared but um
thank you so so much uh Ace says that's
a real thing I'm gonna google it say
mate as soon as we get off this I want
to have a look what it is
um
oh yes yes I'll tell you what Dave is
one of my favorites yeah you're a
[ __ ] genius mate God the man is a
genius I praise for Dave
how good would that be it'd be fantastic
what was the Clint Eastwood movement
where he played this old man Angry old
man like get off my yard all of them
yeah yeah
everything past pale writer
you sir
genius so that that thought real quick
though apparently with Flashpoint not
with Flashpoint with see I already have
the flash as Batman Flashpoint in my
head because John campia on the John
Camp your show is always like they're
gonna change it and and [ __ ] they should
but I Michael Keaton could definitely
play that older Batman right now that's
70 he's 74 75 he could play the older
Batman that was like all right I'm too
old for this Terry McGinnis here you go
all right you know give us something
good yeah they should have done that
with the DC anyway that would have been
Wicked people would have gone nuts if
they'd have broken
uh even Ben Affleck but had Michael
Keaton as the old man but
if they do that this entire conversation
is going to go a very different way
Michael Keaton should have been in the
Batman
I wonder that would have worked
you know James Patterson you're on the
Batman that would have worked actually
that would have worked I I have a bunch
of I like I said you can get me started
on that and we can have a whole nother
video but that would have worked I
believe much better I'll watch it again
and then we'll have an argument about it
because I still think it's a good film
but I just have enough trepidation to
think I think I'm gonna watch this again
and hate it so that means I have to
watch it again and that's going to be at
least 16 sittings because that's it's
not entertaining enough to keep me
watching at all all right theater I fell
asleep twice and woke up and my my
friend did the same thing and we were
both like we were angry as we were
waking back up and like oh this is still
on I mean
four weeks we will do a um thing right
guys uh by the way forward next week um
I'm not actually here but matters very
kindly decided he will um sit in my
chair for me
um I I am sort of I I'm away in my
Caravan for the weekend so I will be on
but I won't be on a computer so Matt's
going to do it for us but we will have a
Halloween special if you guys are up for
it so forget sci-fi
um just come with your favorite
Halloweeny movies and stormy I will pay
you real money if you dress yeah as
defito gambell Danny Gandalf Gandalf
Davido come on please please dress up as
Gandalf Davido
um but depending on my internet signal I
will be here for as much as I can be
depending on Wi-Fi
um so if you want to see Davido Gandalf
please give us a big thumbs up please
put in the comments
for Gandalf DeVito or Davido sunny and I
don't know we need a vote and we can
figure out tell us in the comments is it
going to be Danny Gandalf or Gandalf
DeVito
all right
but hey I will put a poll on in a minute
all right and we will
it's funny that or is it Danny the gray
or
um Gandalf DeVito
I think everyone will get Gandalf to
veto but again uh
it's another DC character that no one
ever remembers exactly but it's absolute
genius so if you want to see stormy all
dressed up
and um and and and and Harris you get
dressed up as well because if you want
to you can do something different
I unfortunately can't I'll be in public
so
um unless I could talk about one more
reason to
stand off
and off that's confusing
um guys thank you again so thank you so
much I will see you next week
um and just again just a brilliant
conversation thank you so much it's
always sunny in Rohan
it is it is
it's over bye guys
bye guys yeah
two dolls
[Music]